if you guys aren't aware a bunch of
small channels have been contacting me
to let me know that fresh and fit have
been striking their channel trying to
get their channels deleted when i heard
about this i was a little surprised
because if you aren't aware how the
copyright system works if you get three
strikes your channel can get terminated
meaning you're permanently off and no
longer make videos ever again for a lot
of people that's their livelihood and so
when you use a copyright system and you
do three strikes you are trying to get
them deleted on youtube you have a
little portion where it says copyright
in your youtube studio and so you can
see what percentage of your video people
are using and we've had hundreds of
people use our content for their videos
generally we allow all of it folks react
focus transform commentary it's part of
how things work h3h3 already took this
to court and won so fair use is pretty
well known on youtube so i'm not gonna
lie to you i was a little disappointed
when i saw this because irrespective of
what you guys may believe i don't want
fresh and fit removed off youtube i
don't want them destroyed i make content
to criticize and to do commentary i
enjoy it we make laughs people go back
and forth it's cool when you want
people's channels deleted i think you go
a step too far you also have to know
that
if you abuse the system and youtube
finds out you can get your channel
terminated folks like jamari spencer
cornelia as well as playback have all
been hit numerous times we haven't been
hit
however
i know what it's like to be a smaller
channel and to not have any recourses i
have a youtube rep i can easily contact
them go through the back door and handle
a lot of this stuff okay but for these
smaller channels they don't have that
same recourse so when you do this when
you threaten their livelihoods i'm like
man what are you thinking and i would
caution the folks over at freshlyfit to
rethink this strategy because i'm
telling you it will get your channel
removed and if youtube now starts to pay
attention to the red pill community a
lot more there's a lot of people are
going to get removed i can tell you guys
this right now there's some folks who've
had multiple channels deleted you're not
supposed to be on youtube anymore if
youtube finds out your new channel will
also get deleted if you guys want to go
through these routes there's a lot of
folks who can get removed i've been said
so many things
about
be it fresh and fit or other red content
that clearly violates terms of service i
would never think of using that to get
at you guys ever
why because if you guys are making money
then good for you i think everybody
should be entitled to their fan base and
to make as much as they want critique
each other disagree whatever it might be
but if you go down this road i'm letting
you know it's often your end that's
going to be hit the hardest we're doing
this video for all the smaller channels
the folks who are undoubtedly going to
get hit by this if you guys are being
hit feel free to message us you the
viewer i'm talking to you guys watching
right now all right the folks who watch
us are really [ __ ] with us okay if you
want to help it's not that difficult you
can either like and comment if you don't
have a twitter and if you do have a
twitter get on twitter and at youtube
and say hey these guys over at
fresherfit are abusing the copyright
system if everyone adds them i promise
youtube will get on it like this and
undo a lot of these strikes because i
think it's unfair that these guys who've
worked really hard for their channels
should have it removed through the abuse
of the copyright system and youtube you
got to figure something out with this
copy it's so easy to abuse i could right
now go out and try to delete seven
channels it wouldn't be that difficult i
would never because i think it's bad
business practice but it's easy to abuse
and youtube has to find a better way to
handle this fair use situation because
it is an issue
um
and this is the last thing i'll say i do
find it rather funny that it's dudes who
claim to have so much confidence
comfortableness in themselves right
alpha males dating coaches who seem to
be the most fragile who seem to have all
these outbursts and get hyper emotional
about everything who abuse a copyright
system and use weird shoddy legal
tactics to get back people in a
vindictive way it's always these types
who do all these things and you know
what's funny is that fresh and fit
themselves actually react to content on
their channel they pay other people's
clips they play other people's videos
all the time that's acceptable if you
guys do it but if other people react to
your stuff all of a sudden it's an issue
what if you guys are wondering where you
preach is preach is currently on tour
doing some comedy stuff so we can't be
here but again i just want to make this
video real quick all right if you guys
want to support again like and comment
so that this video can boost an
algorithm and get seen by more people
and if you have a twitter get on twitter
at youtube and to the other channels are
being hit by this i'm sorry it's unfair